le bon pain au chocolat chocolate
[Music]
knight i am co founder of the
bakery globally the
base population it's good chocolate a pain au
chocolat it's croissant dough with
chocolate bars best
of all  time that the chocolate is
crispy
but these buttered supplements to
precisely have this half and 7 matches
which is specific to the weight of the branches at
the artisanal pole ac it is emblematic and
in chocolate it is very strong
so I am a gallop critic and I
am manager of the saint
georges bakery so young chocolatines it is
a delicious pastries made
from butter flour
essentially and inside there are
two bars of chocolate it is very very good
I can when I fell into the hen c very
constant at  the outside and then
crumble with a bar of
chocolate inside so it's a
chocolate taste that we have a lot of
French people who don't know what
it is when we beat paris  where in the
north of france are in a
chocolatine we don't really look
with big eyes
well me now without any problem
i am chocolatines from toulousaine the
chocolatines are the pride of all the
south of france i obviously want to talk
about the chocolatine and  no
pain au chocolat
even president may cry respect
does not appear between chocolatines and
pain au chocolat and I understood that
teams had torn on this subject
for me it is true that it is a little
strange to  rivalry that there is today
between chocolatine and pain au
chocolat and that has nothing to do with
me I think I think that today
it's a lot of ado about not much
I think that that  it's not chocolate
or chocolatines the limit actually
doesn't matter to the extent not
chocolate chocolatines aux geckos la
chocolatine chocolatines chocolatines
chocolatines good it's not there
[Music]